notre invité votre invité qui est
aujourd'hui robert rochefort bonjour un
jour député européen vice-président du
modem alors sans surprise la motion de
censure contre le gouvernement
évidemment a été rejetée conséquence le
projet de macron est adoptée en première
lecture
qui va partir on le sait pour examen
devant le sénat puis ensuite revenir
devant l'assemblée pour lecture
définitive et donc avec un nouveau vote
est ce que vous me voyez venir retour à
la case départ pour le gouvernement
valls ce qu'il faudra qu'il refasse le
coup du 49-3 pour une validation vous
savez qu'il a le droit de le faire il
n'a droit d'utiliser le 49-3 qu'une
seule fois par session
mais il a le droit de l'utiliser une
deuxième fois j'allais dire s'il s'agit
de confirmer un premier passage si la
commission paritaire mixte n'a pas
réussi à trouver un accord entre les
deux assemblées vous savez c'est cette
histoire et cétaphil a pris ce nom c'est
pas fini pourquoi c'est triste c'est
triste parce que la loi macron c'était
deux choses c'était à la fois un
ensemble de mesures que j'appellerais de
bon sens technique et à côté de cela
présenté par le gouvernement comme une
sorte de deux grands textes fondateurs
de la réforme économique majeur de
françois hollande est en réalité ce
n'était pas ce deuxième aspect par
contre c'était le premier aspect et je
crois que le gouvernement a eu tort de
vouloir à ce point politiser la loi
macron alors qu'en fait c'était un
ensemble de dispositions techniques que
ray du passé sans nécessiter ce grand
départ
comme souvent en france on avait le
sentiment que avec ou sans la loi macron
c'était notre avenir qui se joue est
fondamentalement lorsque c'était pas ça
c'est regrettable de voir que l'esprit
du 11 janvier s'est fracassée si vite
sur la loi macron etc comme constamment
je sais pas si c'est votre aussi votre
analyse de voir que finalement les
conservatismes de gauche comme de droite
se sont alliés pour empêcher de faire
passer une réforme positive qui fait la
loi du siècle françois hollande a dit
qui va dans le bon sens mais je suis pas
tu aurais proposé par la droite aussi
d'ailleurs je pas tout à fait d'accord
sur un point c'est je suis centriste je
ne suis pas de droite je suis pas de
gauche mais c'est quand même là une
crise de la gauche c'est pas la droite
qui est en cause c'est vraiment une
crise de la gauche
alors si vous voulez me faire dit
que la droite dans un même cas de figure
aurait pu vivre le même type de crise
vous avez raison mais là ne mettons ne
faisons pas d'amalgamé
mais vous savez c'est pour cela qu'avec
françois bayrou nous pensons qu'il est
important d'avoir une réforme
institutionnelle qui crée de la
proportionnelle parce que en deux
minutes pour vous expliquer les choses
simplement
quand on est comme aujourd'hui avec un
système d'alternance coup de balai une
chambre rose une chambre bleue une
chambre rose une chambre bleue notre
analyse c'est que à chaque fois du coup
l'idéologie l'emportent sur le
pragmatisme est par exemple si on prend
l'élection de françois hollande et de
l'assemblée qui a suivi on a eu certains
ont pensé que c'était un grand une
grande évolution vers une couleur rose
absolue nous pensons qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a une majorité est une majorité
unique composée d'un seul parti
il y à ce qu'on appelle les extrêmes qui
tire cette majorité
et vous avez vu que ce qui s'est passé
c'est à dire que les contestataires du
parti socialiste se sont crus légitime à
dire c'est un camp idéologique a gagné
et vous trahissez ce camp idéologique
ces députés frondeurs selon vous où ils
doivent rester au ps c'est pas mon
affaire
c'est évidemment pas mon affaire je
pense que en tout cas le parti
socialiste aura du mal à se moderniser
si les gardes mais vous comprenez bien
que c'est pas mon affaire
est-ce qu'il part regrettable robert
rochefort que le gouvernement étant
édulcoré cette loi mâcon pour finalement
devoir la faire passer en force dans une
version minimaliste bien sûr bien sûr
c'est la preuve de sa très grande
faiblesse
il a atteint qu'il a reculé sur beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais le plus
grave c'est pas ça le plus grave c'est
que cet accouchement se fait tellement
par anesthésie générale disons que le
bébé n'est pas né de façon naturelle
il ya un acte chirurgical qui a été
passée du coup on se dit que c'est bien
la dernière des réformes c'est la
première très faible et en même temps la
dernière et ça c'est préoccupant que
c'est l'immobilisme assuré pour les deux
bien sûr ça va être ça va être
probablement avec quelques éléments de
cosmétiques on va nous dire ici ou là
tel ou tel type de choses à rien se
passer mais non le quinquennat le
quinquennat les terre-pleins est finie
le cas des effets du poids du point de
vue des grandes réformes
et puis vous savez le gouvernement
enchaîne la seule réforme territoriale
ce sera pas non plus aussi facile qui
peut le penser
jean marie le pen qui emboîte le pas
robert rochefort à roland dumas qui juge
probable que
des responsables politiques soient sous
influence juive
c'est un soutien qui ne vous surprend
pas non je trouve simplement que
monsieur dumas qui maintenant quelqu'un
de très âgées qui aiment les chaussures
de luxe aurait pu se contenter de ce
goût là et de ne pas nous amener ces
commentaires déplacés et vous dites vous
même qu'il a fait là au cas particulier
d'une certaine façon la courte échelle à
jean marie le pen qui d'ailleurs n'en a
vraiment pas besoin
françois fillon a affirmé hier qu'il
voterait ps en cas de duel ps front
national en 2017 si ça devait arriver
c'est son cinquième changement de
position quatre ans sur le sujet ces
revirements
pour l'instant il a raison donc sur ce
point là il a raison et donc vous n'avez
pas changé d'avis n'allez pas me dire
écoutez chacun à chacun et les positions
qu'il veut au cours du temps au fil du
temps moi en tout état de cause il n'y a
pas doute j'aurais été dans le doubs
j'aurais voté ps aux dernières
législatives
et il va de soi qu'on ne peut pas
considérer qu'il y à parité de danger
entre guillemets entre le camp d'en face
dans le jeu démocratique
et puis le parti de madame le pen vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure robert
rochefort françois bayrou demande plus
de proportionnelle et ne serait pas
choqué qu'il y ait 120 150 députés fn
front national à l'assemblée nationale
vous partager ce point de révéler votre
doute ce pas choquer là vous êtes un peu
provocant non je pense que les dj sera
maps sur dénis serait pas absurde qui
est semble en avoir il ya déjà 24
députés du front national au parlement
européen là où je suis sur 74 députés en
réalité bloque pas grand chose parce
qu'ils ne font rien et ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de bloquer les choses non
dans une démocratie il n'est pas sain
que un courant important ne soient pas
représentés c'est pas sain pour une
raison très simple c'est que ça mais ce
courant d'une certaine façon en
exonération de présenter ce qu'ils
pensent vraiment si les députés du front
national existaient là sont nationales
ils montreraient de même le fait que
leur proposition ne tiennent pas et
évidemment les électeurs la fois d'après
or la possibilité soit d'augmenter
encore le nombre de ses députés de ses
députés ou au contraire de le réduire
les années 90 ils ont eu une vingtaine
de dépouilles l'est ça les a pas
empêchés de progresser
t'es pas au nom des députés vu qu'ils
annoncent aujourd'hui mais le front
national a progressé mais là il a
progressé en restant sur un principe de
contestation du système alors que
lorsqu'il était à l'international il dit
venait ce qui est normal une une partie
du système parce que comme beppe grillo
nathalie qui finalement vu comment il
s'effondre donc il faut pas avoir peur
de la démocratie il ne faut surtout pas
comment dire mettre des sortes de
barrières artificielles parce que on se
les plans on se les prend en boomerang
et d'une certaine façon si on reste avec
un scrutin uninominal à deux tours comme
ça en france
peut-être qu'on aura un jour plus de
députés du front national qu'on en
aurait juste par l'application de la
proportionnelle mais au delà de la
question de la proportionnelle en sexy
le fn prospère c'est parce que la droite
n'a pas de proposition et la gauche n'a
pas de résultat le vrai fond du problème
est là dessus vous savez que nous sommes
tout à fait de cet avis nous sommes dans
un système politique qui est à bout de
souffle
un système qui doit se régénérer comment
doit-il se régénérer en particulier par
le fait que les partis politiques
doivent se remettre en cause et ça
rejoint ce débat que nous avions tout à
l'heure tant qu' il s'agit de deux
d'emmener une grande maison qui est est
ambigu sur ce qu'elle pense vraiment
c'est le cas aujourd'hui du parti
socialiste qui se fait élire sur un
programme auquel d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens ne croient pas mais auquel certains
croient malgré tout et puis ensuite un
président qui se dit c'est pas grave au
bout de deux ans je vais corriger le tir
mais il n'arrive pas à corriger le tir
vous voyez bien que ce système est à
bout de souffle il faut
comment dire moi je ne suis pas pour
l'union nationale à tout prix c'est pas
ça le sujet mais il faut sur un certain
nombre de questions qui sont des
questions essentielles
arrivé à comment dire à l'alliance des
gens de bon sens et je vous garantis que
sur beaucoup de sujets on serait capable
d'y arriver
regardez dans dans les réformes
économiques en général tout le monde
aujourd'hui est d'accord sur le fait que
nous croulons en france sous la halle la
sueur administration la sueur
paperasserie les tracasseries de tous
les autres ont aujourd'hui on veut dire
dans les propositions mais la seule
alliance qu'on assassine alliance
implicite janvier dire entre gauche et
droite
vous avez raison que ça arrange bien de
voir marine le pen au second tour en
2010 est pas ce qui se dit çà sera le
seul moyen peut-être être assuré d'être
élu c'est un jeu très dangereux oui mais
vous savez c'est comme vous savez c'est
comme les oligopoles dans l'économie
quand vous avez deux géants oligopole
tout le monde sait que en fait il se
passe le sel le poivre qui s'entendent
très bien
la théorie économique nos actifs
expliquer ça depuis longtemps c'est
pareil quand il y a deux grands partis
qui d'une certaine façon se passent le
relais du pouvoir tous les cinq ans bon
ben il n'y a pas de souci on accorde
après on revient et on ne règle pas les
problèmes des français et on dégrade la
démocratie et on fabrique une abstention
record et en fabrique des citoyens qui
ne se retrouvent pas dans ce jeu
politique c'est ce que nous nous
dénonçons depuis des années je vais bien
sûr on est d'accord je vais au-delà en
disant quelque part laisser marine le
pen prospérer et lé être au second tour
c'est le meilleur moyen pour le candidat
de droite se soit juppé sarkozy ou à
gauche françois hollande d'être élu ils
ont intérêt ce cas pas de croire au
second tour en dix ans c'est le
attendent rien cela mais attendez
libération c est dur c'est en même temps
un moment de rencontre
si ça doit se produire c'est un moment
de rencontre un défi histoire et ça a
été à mon avis la grande erreur de
jacques chirac puisque le cas a déjà eu
lieu
vous vous en souvenez face à jean marie
le pen c'était une surprise mais mais là
je pense que jacques chirac aurait dû
prendre conscience du fait que il avait
été élu par une large un large
rassemblement il aurait dû en tenir
compte pour refonder la politique
autrement il ne l'a pas fait donc si un
homme ou une femme se trouve dans la
situation que vous venez de décrire bain
libre à lui où il le jouera petit bras
et il le jouera je suis sûr de gagner et
c'est mon camp qui est gagné mais ce
sera très très décevant où il le jouera
en disant ben voila j'ai une
responsabilité historique
je ne suis pas l'élu de mon parti loin
s'en faut
je suis l'élue démocrate et je dois
changer les choses alors êtes-vous pas
convaincu par les propos tenus en ce
moment en direct boursorama par robert
rochefort voilà vous pouvez voter depuis
votre pc depuis votre ordinateur
convaincus ou pas je vous donne les
résultats aidant quelques instants
j'aimerais qu'on parle de françois
bayrou
pourquoi est ce qu'il est si réservé sur
l'idée d'une primaire de la droite et du
centre
quoi c'est parce que sarkozy ne veut pas
en faire une avec lui non c'est parce
que en fait la primaire d'abord raté du
centre veut dire que vous êtes parvenu à
80 % des gens me disent convaincus joli
score
je remercie alors et donc j'ai pas été
bon non mais pourquoi vous n'êtes pas là
pour qu'ils en ont bien sûr non parce
que être candidats à une primaire ça
veut dire accepter
résultat de la primaire et vous voyez
bien que si nicolas sarkozy gagne la
primaire françois bayrou ne veut pas
décidé d'emblée de dire je vais je vais
m'allier avec nicolas sarkozy
parce que comme vous le savez françois
bayrou s'est opposé à nicolas sarkozy
alors si je dois ajouter ma touche
personnelle parce que je ne suis pas que
le proche de françois bayrou je pense
que tout dépendra de la façon dont
nicolas sarkozy mène sa campagne depuis
quelques quelques semaines ce qui me
fera beaucoup c'est qu'on ne sait pas
très bien sur quel positionnement il est
est ce qu'il va retrouver un
positionnement très très idéologique à
son tour très adroite marqué par l'idée
que pour limiter marine le pen il faut
chasser sur ses plates-bandes moi je
pense que c'est le construire moi je
pense que c'est le contraire je pense
que je pense que c'est ce qu'il a perdu
et je pense que ça a contribué à
diffuser un certain nombre d'idées du
front national ait raté son retour en
politique
il décollera dans le guépard il n'est
pas réussi mais comment dire il a un peu
de temps devant lui non il est pas il
n'y a pas réussi ces gens qu'on puisse
dire françois bayrou a déclaré récemment
si juppé gagne la primaire je l'aiderai
est ce qu'il ya un accord tacite
implicite entre bayrou et juppé en gros
tu y vas bayrou qui dirait juppé tu y
vas je me présente pas et puis vous
savez on dirait que je viens avec toi
matignon lors d'abord bordeaux
l'aquitaine c'est ma circonscription
donc je connais bien cette situation non
il n'y a pas d'accord au sens où il y
aurait justement ce que l'on ne veut pas
c'est à dire des gens qui voient là qui
roulent derrière que s'ils
redescendaient attendez attendez on sait
pas tout à fait ça il se trouve que sur
beaucoup de sujets ils partagent la même
analyse
et c'est ça qui est fondamental
aujourd'hui la question qui est la
question qui intéresse des citoyens
c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
réduire le chômage
la grande différence où vous voyez bien
entre nicolas sarkozy et alain juppé
sait qu'alain juppé dit il faut un
certain nombre de mesures extrêmement
clair mais il faut rassemblement pour le
faire et ce rassemblement doit aller
vers le centre et le centre udi le
centre modem et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'il fait à bordeaux et j'ai beaucoup
aimé lorsque alain juppé a été sifflé
dans des meetings deux fois une paix il
a répondu à ses détracteurs
vous savez si je ne devais n'avoir que
les gens de l'ump comme elle est
heures je n'aurais pas été réélu à la
mairie de bordeaux parce qu'à la mairie
de sur la ville de bordeaux
françois hollande a été largement
majoritaires donc ce qu'il faut et on
voit bien alain juppé quelqu'un qui
rassemble au delà du strict sens du
triste champ alors maintenant si vous me
permettez une petite remarque je pense
qu'alain juppé est extrêmement
légitimiste et que françois bayrou est
un peu transgressif
alors est-ce que les deux s'entendront
je veux dire par là que alain juppé a
l'air de dire que quel que soit le
résultat des primaires est ici pire est
donc ça veut dire que si c'était pas lui
qui gagnait il se rallierait et il se
rallierait à celui qui égale la primaire
et c'est là où il ya évidemment les
hôtels difficulté sinon nicolas sarkozy
gagne cette primaire françois bayrou
coûte que coûte
il reste présent jamais pourquoi je
crois pas qu'il faut poser le problème
comme ça en tout cas pour s'en servir ou
pour faudra bayrou y la question se
posera la question se posera et tout
dépendra à mon avis de la plateforme qui
sera celle de nicolas sarkozy de son
positionnement
mais il y aura évidemment le désir la
volonté d'avoir une voix centristes
parce qu'il faut quand même pas oublier
que la présidentielle c'est l'idée d'y à
deux tours il ya un tour où on exprime
son choix et un deuxième tour on choisit
alors je vous accorde que quand les
sondages nous disent tous les matins
comment dire marine le pen sera sûrement
au second tour on a un peu on voit bien
que les grands partis vous en parlez
vous même tout à l'heure sont tentés de
dire du coup le premier tour ça devient
les primaires et c'est plus le premier
tour devant des électeurs
nous ne voulons pas de cela pour nous le
premier tour devant les électeurs il est
absolument fondamentale et d'ailleurs
l'élection présidentielle c'est le vrai
moment de rencontre entre les français
et est un projet politique il faut pas
le rater
mais vous comprenez que l'électorat de
droite en veuille à votre patron à
françois bayrou il a voté
il a fait appeler à voter hollande et
faire perdre sarkozy
voilà je crois est ce que là il passe de
wingles il récupère le plus en direct
françois bayrou nicolas sarkozy a
confirmé bon écouter en direct par le
truchement 9e barça je ne sais pas je
sais qu'ils se sont toujours parler
quand il fallait se parler c'est là
c'est ça qui est important
de même que françois bayrou et françois
hollande se sont toujours parler quand
il fallait se parler après pour le reste
ça n'a pas beaucoup d'importance
ce que vous venez de me dire la wii
black c'est un guy mixer 7 artificiel
c'est à dire que vous voyez bien que il
y a dans le fait de 10
françois bayrou seraient condamnées
définitivement parce qu'il a voté à
titre personnel d'ailleurs je vous le
rappelle pour françois hollande
non c'est c'est une façon comment dire
d'avoir un jeu interne au sein de la
droite c'est pas le vrai sujet parce que
vous avez bien vu que à pau françois
bayrou a été capable d'avoir un très
large rassemblement avec les
responsables locaux de l'ump ceux de
l'ue dit certes un socialiste repenti
j'allais dire donc non françois bayrou
est tout à fait capable d'avoir un
rassemblement et il n'est pas réductible
loin s'en faut au fait d'avoir voté
françois hollande vous parlez robert
rochefort de l'udi lui dit le modem de
parti centriste n'a pas trop écouter on
a commencé à travailler ensemble on
s'est fait élire au scrutin européen
ensemble dans beaucoup de mairies y
compris du côté de l'aquitaine il ya eu
beaucoup d'alliances qu'ont permis
d'avoir beaucoup de mairies dans les
élections qui arrivent les élections
départementales dans beaucoup de cas de
figure nos candidats seront des
candidats pas toujours mais très souvent
des candidats d'alliance donc l'alliance
l'alliance est toujours quelque chose
d'un petit peu difficile il ya eu la
succession de jean louis borloo qui a un
peu perturbé les choses il faut bien le
dire
nous continuons en tout cas à vouloir
qu'il y ait un centre fort et donc à
s'entraîner imaginons en deux ce qui est
en dessous telle est la question
on est en 2010 cette deuxième tour
françois hollande face à nicolas sarkozy
que fait françois bayrou
bon bah écoutez je crois qu'il regardera
comme il l'a fait la dernière fois
d'abord j'espère ne sera pas ça parce
que si c'est pas marine le pen j'espère
que le foie françois bayrou face à l'un
des deux mais si ça devait se produire
il fera comme nous l'avons fait la
dernière fois c'est là qu'on regardera
propositions propres ambitions
n'oubliez jamais que si françois bayrou
n'a pas voulu s'allier avec nicolas
sarkozy lors du deuxième tour des
dernières présidentielles c'est à cause
de ce que vous appelez vous même la
ligne buisson
c'est à cause d'un certain nombré pas
une tonne de questions c'était des
questions de valeurs et de valeurs qui
étaient mises en avant et qui étaient
des valeurs de fractures de la société
et vous vois bien presque trois jours
trois ans après pardon avec les
événements qui se déroulent les grandes
tensions de notre pays que il ne faut
pas rajouter de la tension à de la
tension en créant des fractures
idéologiques inutiles et stériles et
qu'il faut au contraire rassembler voilà
merci on verra là dessus merci à vous
robert rochefort député européen
et vice-président du modem merci